Ich bin hier zuständige Assistenz, mit ihnen werde ich das Annamnese-Gespräch führen.
Bevor wir über ihre aktuelle Beschwerden sprechen, möchte ich ein paar Algemeine fragen.
Sind Sie damit ein Verstandener?
Ja.
Okay.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Olaf Schmidt.
Olaf Schmidt.
Ist Ihre Nachname mit Date oder Double Tea?
Double Tea.
Okay. Herr Schmidt.
Okay.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ja, ich bin 75 Jahre alt.
75.
Okay.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 2.02.1947.
1947.
Ja, genau.
Okay.
Wie groß sind Sie und wie viel wegen Sie?
Ich bin 1,75 Meter groß und wiegt 82 kg.
82 kg.
82.
Okay.
Herr Schmidt, was führt Sie zu uns?
Ich habe seit drei Wochen Schmerzen im rechten Kniegelenk.
Ich bin mit meiner Frau wandern gegangen, lange Strecke gelaufen.
Dann habe ich gemerkt, dass mein reches Knie weh tut.
Und dieser Schmerz im rechten Kniegelenk, die nimmt immer mehr zu.
Immer zu.
Das ist ein zunehmender Schmerz.
Nein, wenn die Schmerzen da sind.
Okay.
Sind Sie gestürzt?
Nein.
Ich habe keinen Unfall gehabt.
Okay.
Ich bin gestürzt.
Wir sind nur spazierengegangen, lange Strecke.
Nein, nach Wandern.
Sie kommen mit Ihren Schmerzen.
Okay.
Wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala von 0 bis 10,
wenn 0 ist keine Schmerzen und 10 sehr starke Schmerzen meint?
Ich würde sagen 7.
7.
Sind Ihre Schmerzen dauerhaft oder willen für mich?
Ich würde sagen belastungsabhängig.
Wenn ich nicht viel tue, wenn ich sitze, schlafe, habe ich keinen Schmerzen.
Nur wenn ich Lauf, Treppen laufen möchte oder längere Strecke gehe,
dann habe ich Schmerzen im rechten Kniegelenk.
Okay, verstanden.
Sind Ihre Schmerzen plötzlich begonnen?
Nein, langsam.
Vor drei Wochen nach dem Spaziergang,
hat es begonnen nach dem Spaziergang.
Und jetzt immer mehr, immer mehr,
immer stärker auf die Schmerzen.
Ich würde sagen, wie ein Messer stehe ich.
Sind Ihre Schmerzen in anderen Körperregionen aus?
Ja, vielleicht in meinen Unterschenkeln.
Und vom Knie zu meiner Warte oder unterschenken.
Unterschenken, verstanden.
Okay, jetzt gibt es eine Auslöser für Ihre Schmerzen.
Auslöser, dass die Spazierungen gehen.
Ja, genau.
Okay, gibt es etwas, das Ihre Schmerzen verstärkt?
Verstärkt oder lindert?
Verstärkt ist, wenn ich spazieren gehe,
ich lege die Belastung und lindere die Schmerzen.
Wenn ich es kühle, zum Beispiel.
Oder in den Schmerzmittel einnehme.
Nehmen Sie dagegen irgendwelche Medikamente?
Ja, ich habe zu Hause Ibuprofen.
Ibuprofen, wie viel Milligramm?
400 Milligramm habe ich zu Hause.
19 Jahre, jetzt habe ich dich.
Ich habe 400 Milligramm.
Wenn Sie sich schmerzen, dann nehme ich die ein.
Hat Ibuprofen Ihnen geholfen?
Ja, ein bisschen.
Nicht viel, aber ein bisschen lindert.
Meine lindert ein bisschen, leichte Schmerzen.
Ja, verstanden.
Sie sind nicht weg.
Ja, genau.
Ja, gibt es Fieber oder füllen Sie sich fieberich an Ihrer betroffenen Knie?
Fieberik, nein, Fieber habe ich nicht.
Wärmegefühl habe ich manchmal.
Haben Sie das bemerkt?
Manchmal, aber nicht immer.
Okay, ist Ihre betroffene Knie geschwollen?
Nein, ich würde nicht so sagen.
Ein bisschen, aber eigentlich nicht so.
Können Sie Ihre Beine stecken?
Beugen ist eingeschränkt.
Meine linke Seite kann ich besser beugen aus der rechten Seite.
Die ist endgradig eingeschränkt.
Die Beugung.
Strecken geht.
Okay, Herr Schmidt, haben Sie Fieber?
Fieber habe ich nicht.
Kusten Sie?
Nein.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Ist Ihnen übel?
Übelkeit habe ich auch nicht.
Die Fragen sind über Ihre aktuelle Zustand.
Deswegen stelle ich diese Frage.
Wie ist Ihr Appatit?
Normal.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ungewöhnlich abgenommen?
Nein, nichts Besonderes.
Okay.
Rast, Ihr Herz?
Nein.
Haben Sie Herzklopfen?
Nur wenn ich meine Frau sehe jeden Tag.
Ja, Sie verlieben Ihre Frau.
Natürlich, wir leben ja seit Jahren zusammen.
Okay.
Herr Schmidt, haben Sie krönliche Erkrankungen,
von denen ich wissen sollte?
Ja, ich nehme Medikamente wegen Bluthochdruck.
Seit wann leiden Sie daran?
Seit 15 Jahren.
Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie dagegen?
Am April, 10 Jahre.
Ja, ich nehme Medikamente wegen Bluthochdruck.
Und wie lange nehmen Sie dagegen?
Am April, 10 Milligramm.
Täglich 2 Tage.
Ja, morgens, abends.
Okay.
Haben Sie ansonsten krönliche Erkrankungen?
Der Arzt hat mir noch,
wie meine Cholesterie noch in Medikamente gegeben.
Ich nehme 20 Milligramm, abends eine.
Abends eine.
Ansonsten nehme ich keine Medikamente ein.
Okay, ein Verstand.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, ich hatte mal ein Außenknöschelbruch.
Wie bitte?
Könnten Sie bitte wiederholen?
Ich hatte mal in meinem Sprunggelenk
einen Außenknöschelbruch gehabt.
Okay.
Wann wurden Sie operiert?
Das war vor 40 Jahren.
40 Jahre. Okay.
Aber haben Sie keine Konflikation?
Nein, das war alles gut verheilt.
Okay.
Ich habe noch ein paar Prüfen.
Haben Sie noch,
oder wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Weiter nicht. Das war die einzige OP, die ich jetzt hatte.
Okay.
Herr Schimmitz,
nehmen Sie regelmäßig
unser Ramipril und Simvastatin und Ibuprofen.
Andere Medikamente ein?
Nein.
Herr Schimmitz, reagieren Sie auf bestimmte Nahrungsmittel
oder Medikamente allergisch?
Allergisch, ja.
Ich darf kein Penicillin einnehmen.
Hatte ich mal früher eingenommen, weiß ich nicht warum.
Und da hatte ich mal einen Atemnot gehabt.
Und deswegen nehme ich das nicht mehr ein.
Ja, Penicillin ist eine Antibiotik.
Ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie Unverträglichkeit gegenüber jetzt was?
Ich hatte mal die Klophenac eingenommen gehabt.
Und da hatte ich Magen-Schmerzen bekommen.
Da habe ich nicht gut vertragen.
Magen-Schmerzen macht das.
Chemf-Magen-Schmerzen, ja.
Und Durchfall.
Herr Schimmitz, haben alle Gurundimpfungen Anhaltungen?
Also, wenn Sie jetzt aktuell wegen dem Corona-Gesicht,
da habe ich alle Impfungen hinter mir.
Kinderimpfungen.
Ich denke schon, weiß ich nicht mehr.
Das war damals nicht alles irgendwie,
da hat sich kein Ausweis von meinen Eltern bekommen.
Haben Sie Impfungen dabei?
Ja, ich habe jetzt einen Ausweis, der seit 20 Jahren gültig ist.
Da bin ich gegen Tetanus geimpft.
Einige Sachen, aber die Kinderimpfungen weiß ich nicht, ob ich alle hatte.
Okay, einfach.
Okay.
Waren Sie in der SIP-Welt?
Die kindliche Impfungen sind unklar.
Ich denke schon, aber weiß ich nicht.
Waren Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland?
In letzter Zeit in Ausland, nee.
In den letzten zwei Jahren Corona, da verlassen sich Deutschland nicht.
Ja, wir sind auch immer noch immer in Deutschland.
Rauchen Sie?
Rauchen, nein.
Haben Sie früher geraucht?
Nee.
Okay, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, so ein klasse Weinabend zum Essen, trinke ich schon, ja.
Trinken Sie täglich, ein oder zweimal?
Täglicher nicht, ich würde sagen,
zwei, drei Mal im Woche.
Nicht jeden Abend, aber kündig mir abends mal.
Trinken Sie besonders Wein, oder?
Ja, ich trinke es, ich trinke es, ich trinke es.
Ich trinke es, ich trinke es, ich trinke es.
Trinken Sie besonders Wein, oder?
Ja, ein Glas Wein, also auch nicht viel.
Okay, Herr Schmidt, Sie sind über 70 Jahre alt,
aber ich muss fragen, nehmen Sie Drogen?
Nein, ich weiß noch nicht mal, wie Drogen geschrieben wird.
Alles klar.
Okay, Herr Schmidt, leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Nein.
Woran sind Ihre Eltern gestorben?
Mein Vater, der ist im Krieg verstorben.
Und Krieg.
Krieg, ah ja, okay.
Im Moment geben Sie nicht Krieg,
natürlich, das war 47 Jahre alt, der war im Krieg verletzt
und an seiner Verletzung war er verstorben.
Da war ich ein kleines Kind, also ich kenne meinen Vater nicht.
Ja.
Und meine Mutter, die ist, weiß ich nicht, die war 80 Jahre alt
und altersbedingt, denke ich, Herzinfarkt,
weiß ich nicht, was da war.
Ja, okay.
Wahrscheinlich Herzinfarkt.
Sind Sie einst, Liebkind?
Ich habe noch einen Bruder.
Lebt Ihr Bruder noch?
Nee, der lebt nicht mehr.
Wissen Sie?
Ja, der hatte einen Krebserkrankung gehabt.
Krebserkrankung.
Lungenkrebs.
Ja, ich habe auch ein Krebserkrankung gehabt.
Ja, leider.
Okay, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie verheiratet sind.
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Ja, und ja, haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe zwei Kinder, ein Sohn und eine Tochter.
Ja, sind Ihre Kinder auch gesund?
Ja, ich weiß schon, der Sohn ist ein bisschen übergewichtig.
Aber ich weiß nicht, dass er Medikamente eignet.
Ich denke, dass die beide gesund sind.
Sie leben mit Ihrer Frau?
Mit meiner Frau zusammengenommen.
Meine Kinder wohnen nicht mehr im Haus.
Sie sind selbst verheiratet und leben anders.
Ja, okay.
Sind Sie im Rentner?
Ja, genau, ich bin Rentner.
Können Sie oder konnten Sie vor der Schmerzen regelmäßig Sport treiben?
Nein, ich verheirate mit meiner Frau und wir gehen spazieren.
Wir reisen gerne.
Ich mache keine regelmäßige Sport wie Tennis oder Fußball.
Wir gehen gerne spazieren.
Ab und zu gehen wir auch stimmen.
Früher hatten Sie ähnliche Beschwerden.
Nicht, dass ich mich erinnern kann.
Herr Schmidt, ich möchte für Sie kurz zusammenfassen.
Sie haben seit drei Wochen am rechten Knie Schmerzen.
Sie sind im Moment.
Und bei der Belastung sind sich ihre Schmerzen verschlimmert.
Vielleicht noch mal neu, ich habe es nicht verstanden.
Beide Belastung sind ihre Schmerzen schlimmert.
Genau.
Man kann auch sagen, die Schmerzen sind belastungsabhängig.
Sie haben, okay, Sie nehmen bei Bedarf Ibuprofen 400 mg ein.
Es heißt ihnen.
Müssen Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, sind Sie fertig?
Ja, von meiner Seite habe ich alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Okay.
Wie geht es jetzt weiter, Frau Doktor?
Zuerst werden wir sie körperlich untersuchen.
Beide Untersuchungen werden wir ihre Bewegung kontrollieren.
Ich werde Sie für Ihre Bewegung veranlassen.
Ich werde Sie für Ihre Bewegung kontrollieren.
Sie haben eine Magnetresonanstomografie.
Was ist das?
Das ist Bildgebändesverfahren.
Es ist schmerzlos und strahlenfrei.
Für diesen Verfahren brauchen wir keine Vorbereitung.
Es dauert maximal 20 Minuten.
Wir können eine klinische Anatomie und eine pathologische Befunde beurteilen.
Okay.
Frau Doktor, was denken Sie, was ich haben könnte?
Natürlich müssen Sie erst untersuchen usw.
Was ist Ihre Meinung?
Was könnte ich haben?
Meine Meinung nach haben Sie weichte Gewebeverletzungen.
Wegen dieser Verletzungen haben Sie Knischmerzen.
Sie können nicht gut beugen und nicht gut flach liegen.
Okay.
Okay, dann schauen wir, wie es dann weitergeht.
Nach der Besprechung mit meinem Oberarzt werde ich wiederkommen.
Ich erkläre alles.
Okay, danke.
Bitte schön.
Bitte.
Meine Fuß nicht, meine Knie tut weh.
Das könnte 5 k m laufen.
Ich könnte auch 2 km laufen, aber es tut mehr weh.
concerns THIS
fühlen Sie sich taupaus gefühlt mit Empfindung und Kraftverlust mit oder ohne Schmerzen.
Die nochmal bitte habe ich nicht verstanden akustisch.
fühlen Sie sich taupaus gefühlt mit Empfindung, Kraftverlust mit oder ohne Schmerzen.
fühlen Sie sich taupaus gefühlt mit Empfindung und Kraftverlust mit oder ohne Schmerzen.
Haben Sie Hautverfärbungen bemerkt?
Nein, eine Verfärbung ist gleich wie ein linker Bein.
Ist die Bein dicker geworden?
Nein, mein Kniegelenk ist ganz leicht, aber nicht so, dass ich sagen würde, dass es sehr dick ist.
Diese Fragen sind gestellt.
Okay, anscheinend gibt es keine weitere Fragen.
Ja, können wir weiter machen.
Hallo, guten Tag Herr Oberhals. Ich habe einen neuen Patientin aufgenommen.
Herr Olaf Schmidt ist 75 Jahre alt und 82 und 1 Meter 75 groß.
82, was?
82 Kilogramm schwer.
Und 1 Meter 75 groß.
Herr Olaf Schmidt stellte sich bei uns wegen Zeit 3 Wochen, 5-täherender Knie Schmerzen an.
Sie haben sich mit den Schmerzen aufgenommen.
Der Patient reagiert auf Penicillin allergisch und erhabe Unverzwecklichkeit gegen Bodycrophenac.
Er sei gegen Corona vollständig geimpft und er sei sein Kindimpfstatus sei unklar.
Er sei nicht traurig.
Er sei verheiratet.